this video is sponsored by shipstation
grow your business all year long with
fast easy shipping and up to 84 off
shipping rates use the link in the
description to sign up for a free 60-day
trial
hi my name is James McIntyre when I was
younger it was discovered that I had a
congenital abnormality in my heart valve
which at the time wasn't significant
enough to be a problem but in 2027 at
age 36 I was diagnosed with mild to
moderate aortic valve disease as a
consequence of this abnormality around
the same time I was also laid off for my
job as a graphic designer my career
which I dedicated most of my life to has
been largely automated out of existence
I come from a low income family raised
by a single mother my father died when I
was five years old I have no health
insurance or way of affording to pay out
of pocket for the surgery I need in
order to repair or replace my heart
valve without treatment my condition
will likely get much worse and could
lead to heart failure
please consider me for the Goliath show
it could save my life thank you
James click submit on the website form
every month hundreds of thousands of
people like James applied to compete in
the largest game show in history the
Goliath show it was the most significant
entertainment phenomenon of the 21st
century an average of 600 million
viewers across the world consumed each
episode which were distributed monthly
on several major streaming platforms the
show is hosted by the content creator
turned business Mogul turn producer and
TV host Danny Howard one of if not the
most famous person in the world
on the show contestants competed in a
variety of simple but absurd large-scale
challenges like who can find the needle
in the largest Haystack ever made who
can win the most consecutive games of
rock paper scissors who can stand in a
giant Circle the longest who can win the
world's largest game of hide and seek
who can stay the longest in a massive
freezer stuff like that
on the surface the Goliath show was fun
and games but for many of its
contestants it was life or death
at the time around 27 percent of the
nation's population was completely
without health insurance 63 percent were
considered inadequately insured with
coverage that didn't provide affordable
access to Essential Medical Treatments
250 million people total some of whom
desperately needed certain Medical Care
and the grand prizes of the Goliath show
challenges were fully paid life-saving
Medical Treatments
[Music]
every month multiple times a month James
went on to the Goliath shows casting
website filled out the submission form
providing the required personal
information photos a brief description
regarding his current medical situation
and a short video clip after over a year
of trying James had not heard anything
participants on the show were selected
through strict criteria primarily based
on the viewership demand for particular
demographics the individual's on-camera
abilities and most importantly their
story The more emotional and higher
Stakes the better
the show is not a charity it was a
business it could afford a certain
amount of its costs going toward
contestant winnings but only by ensuring
viewership was high when the contestant
stories were more dire and sometimes
tragic they made for greater more
engaging episodes with higher stakes and
larger spectacles of emotion and joy
which brought in more viewers and more
money but there were lots of people in
dire need of Medical Treatments so it
was almost impossible to get on the show
As Time continued on for James his
condition worsened as the calcium
buildup on his aortic valve increased
without treatment his valve continued to
narrow and restrict blood flow he
actively sought alternative options for
treatment like charity care and
discounts but didn't qualify he began to
occasionally experience things like
chest pains dizziness and fatigue it was
becoming increasingly difficult and
serious throughout this time James
continued to regularly submit audition
applications still with no luck
on each new application James updated
his wording to reflect his increasingly
dire situation and improve his chances
of being selected
eventually after many months of doing
this one day James received an email
from the show's casting department when
he realized he had his body and hands
began to shake as he immediately opened
the email on his phone it read dear
James McIntyre thank you for applying to
be on the Goliath show we have reviewed
your submission and we absolutely love
your story we think it could potentially
be a fantastic fit for the show if
you're still interested in able we
invite you to the next step in our
screening process and in-person audition
you might even get a chance to meet
Danny you will find all the scheduling
and location details in the subsequent
email we look forward to seeing you
you're one step closer to a Goliath
prize
James looked down at his phone
completely overwhelmed with excitement
and hope amidst the vast choppy sea of
hopelessness in which he had been
aimlessly floating he was now finally
being thrown a life buoy
several weeks later James took two
different buses to a large Convention
Center where the Goliath shows in-person
auditions were being held when he
arrived he sat waiting in a large open
hall for several hours surrounded by
other auditioners a large portion of
them had visibly obvious signs of poor
health some people had missing limbs
others appear blind with someone else
there to help them navigate others just
looked exhausted
eventually James number was called he
got up and was directed to a small
sectioned off Booth inside he sat down
across from two female members of the
casting department and a camera Hi how
are we doing one of the women asked good
yeah how about you guys James responded
oh you know real busy these days are
always crazy yeah James responded yeah
so why don't you tell us a bit about
yourself sure well my name is James
McIntyre I'm 38 years old I have severe
aortic valve disease I haven't been able
to afford the surgery I need for almost
over two years now I used to work in
graphic design but I was laid off around
the same time I was diagnosed now I'm
working as a grocery clerk but my
condition is getting increasingly bad
and it can be pretty hard being on my
feet all the time since the condition
can make me tired and out of breath
sometimes I don't really have anyone in
my life who can help at this point I I
don't really have anywhere else I can
turn it's pretty embarrassing to be here
actually embarrassing one of the women
interjected most people are pretty
excited to have a chance to be on the
Goliath show no I mean I am excited it's
just under these circumstances it's a
little weird I guess hmm okay the woman
said she looked down and marked an x on
James application on the tablet in front
of her why do you think we should choose
you the other woman asked
um well because I believe I deserve a
shot as much as anyone else and my
mother's also been dealing with some
health issues recently if I don't get
treatment I could
I could I could die
I don't know who would even take care of
my mother if I did
my doctor said I could have as little as
a couple years left if I don't figure
something out
it's just it's been really hard it's
James eyes began to water and his voice
became shaky he looked down sorry he
continued looking back up that's okay
the woman said she deleted the X on her
tablet and added a green check mark in a
separate box in the form that read
strong emotion okay that should be all
we need here if you can just go back out
and wait in the waiting area they'll
call you when it's your group's turn for
the moxine okay sure James said James
got up and returned to the waiting area
he waited for several more hours until
eventually he was directed to a separate
area where he acted out a test scene in
which he participated in a small rock
paper scissors tournament with the
stand-in host and other auditioners
then he returned home
several weeks went by James hadn't heard
anything
he reached out several times to the same
email address he received the invite
from but didn't receive anything back
then as James was about to give up on
the whole thing he received another
email from the casting Department it
read dear James congratulations we are
thrilled to inform you that you have
officially been selected to appear on
the Goliath show we hope you're as
excited as we are you will be receiving
further details in a subsequent email
about date time and location please let
us know if you have any questions thank
you and good luck
James entire body went numb he was so
exhausted and overwhelmed he could
barely process the information this was
it possibly his only chance to survive
alone in his apartment he began to break
down in tears
two months later James was flown out to
the main studio and headquarters of the
Goliath show he sat on the plane looking
out the window imagining his future if
he won in his head he saw himself in old
age with good health he saw his normal
life back and a sense of peace that had
now become entirely foreign to him
on the day of the taping James promptly
arrived at the studio at 7 30 am it was
a giant Warehouse with large ornate
indoor and outdoor sets he waited in the
portion of the warehouse that still
looked like a warehouse metal framed
walls fluorescent lighting and cement
floors other contestants began showing
up and waited alongside him the call
time was for 8 am but it wasn't until
around 10 30 a.m that James and the rest
of his group were finally directed into
one of the sets
the group of 200 people were herded into
a section made of giant wooden walls
that were brightly painted on one side
on the floor there were bright lights
and vibrantly painted lines and shapes
the group waited there for another 45
minutes or so James looked around at the
people he would presumably be competing
against still not even sure what they
would be doing then several contestants
gasped James looked in the direction
they had turned it was Danny Howard the
entire group began to applaud cheer and
Shout his name as he walked onto the set
James looked around and joined in on the
Clapping Danny gestured at the group to
stop the Applause but did so in a way
that seemed to almost subversively
welcome more of it
as the group finally began to calm down
somewhat awkwardly Danny said so are we
ready to have a great show yes the crowd
yelled good good that's the kind of
energy we're looking for just keep that
up and this will be a great show Danny
turned around toward the production crew
are we all set he asked yup good to go a
voice echoed back Danny walked over and
stood in a spot marked by tape on the
ground nine camera operators finalized
their position several crew members made
some final adjustments to some of the
contestants positions a male crew member
physically moved James to a spot
slightly further in the back after a
moment someone yelled from behind the
cameras
five four three two then suddenly Danny
began yelling at the cameras in this
challenge the 200 people behind me will
be going head to head in a goliath-sized
cup game whoever's left at the end and
gets all the right cups will receive a
life-changing potentially life-saving
grand prize if you pick the wrong cup
you're out but there's a catch every
round another cut will be added and
these are no ordinary cups cut the same
distant voice from before yelled out
let's get a couple more of those the
intro is so abrupt and loud it
completely startled James again Danny
yelled more or less the same thing at
the cameras then again and again the
camera's cut and each contestant was
given tablets along with the breakdown
of the rules then the cameras cut back
on and the challenge began without
further Ado bringing the giant cups
several crew members slid three giant
red cups that look to be at least six
feet tall into the center of the set
they were numbered one two and three
Danny rolled a giant ping pong ball
underneath one of the cups as they
lifted it up the crew members then began
to quickly shift the cups around as they
ran around each other in alternated cups
James intensely followed the cup with
the ball in it then the cup stopped
moving alright Danny yelled select your
cup James selected number two on his
tablet after a brief moment Danny yelled
okay 33 of you selected cup number one
let's see if it's cup number one lift
cup number one two crew members lifted
up cup number one
there was no ball red X's appeared on 33
of the contestants tablets they were
then directed off the set by several
crew members anyone who picked cup
number one is officially out but no
don't worry you won't be going
home everyone will be going home with
the goliath-sized goodie bag filled with
Goliath show merch and other prizes and
for you at home brand new Goliath show
merch is available at goliathshow.com we
have some great new drops over there so
check that out but act fast because they
will sell out alright so who said cup
number three Danny continued a small
portion of the contestants raised their
hand Danny walked over to one woman
whose hand was raised do you think it's
three yeah I hope so she said hesitantly
and what would winning today's grand
prize mean for you Danny said
well I have sarcoma which is soft tissue
cancer and I currently can't afford
chemo so winning today would would
guarantee that treatment she said wow
well good luck I'm rooting for you Danny
said
cup number three was lifted up no ball
cup number two if you picked cup number
two congratulations you officially made
it past the first round but remember it
only gets harder from here bring in the
extra cup Danny yelled
an extra cup was slid in and again the
ball was rolled under one before the
cups were quickly shifted around for
three more rounds James picked the right
cups each time was more and more
difficult filled with increasing
pressure and disorientation James had
never been more stressed and
uncomfortable in his life with each
round though more and more people were
eliminated starting at 200 it was now
down to 35 people including James
on the fifth round while James was
tracking the cups suddenly A Pair of
Hands briefly appeared over his eyes it
was a crew member who was laughing James
moved his head away and continued to
follow the cup after the cup stopped
James turned toward the crew member and
angrily yelled hey what the hell whoa
whoa you can't get mad this is part of
the show we do that to everyone if you
react like that we can't even use your
shot James looked confused okay my bad I
didn't realize he said
James looked back down and selected cup
number seven on his tablet after each
cup was slowly and dramatically raised
again he selected right
another four rounds went by and James
continued to pick correctly there were
now 11 cups and eight people
Danny walked over toward James all the
cameras pointed at him over here we
still have James left how are you
feeling James Danny said nervous but but
good I'm gonna win James said love the
confidence what would winning today mean
for you James
I mean it would save my life
one of the camera operators zoomed in
tighter on James face I have a pretty
bad heart condition that's getting
really serious my valve doesn't allow
enough blood to get through in a pretty
basic surgery would save my life I need
to win I'm going to win James concluded
his eyes were glassy covered in a sheath
of Tears he was holding back wow okay
James well good luck you know I'm
rooting for you let's move those cups
Danny concluded
the 11 cups were shifted around rapidly
by dozens of crew members with all his
energy all his Focus the most he's ever
exhibited in his life James followed the
cup he believed had the ball
then the cup stopped James selected cup
number eight on his tablet
the crew members began lifting up the
cups cup won nothing cup ten Nothing Cut
four nothing cup 11 nothing
cup eight James cup
nothing
a red X appeared on James tablet he
watched in horror and disbelief as the
cups continued lifting up until finally
cup number three was revealed to have
the ball congratulations to our two
finalists Julia and Donald the only two
who
one else has officially been eliminated
Danny said in the same voice tone
two crew members approached James and
directed him off the set and back toward
the waiting area
I'm confused James said in shock his
voice trembling what happens next he
asked is that the only group number you
were assigned the crew member responded
I I think so James said confused
okay then that's it
the exit is the same way you came in
just down through the middle here and
then to the right your goodie bag is on
the way out too your travel arrangements
and everything else are all in the
initial email that we sent you have a
good one the crew member quickly walked
away mumbling something into his
earpiece
James slowly walked back down through
the warehouse and out the door he came
in
16 months later James was at home
cleaning his apartment After
experiencing an extreme case of
shortness of breath he took a break and
lay on his couch
he put on the Goliath show
he breathed heavily as Danny Howard's
voice echoed through his apartment
he lay back holding his chest his face
clenched in discomfort
then
his eyes closed
[Music]
foreign
thank you for watching this video was
sponsored by shipstation the world is
constantly moving faster and becoming
more automated and consequently our
expectations have also increased when it
comes to getting things free and fast
shipping has become more and more the
norm but this can make it difficult for
smaller e-commerce businesses and
personal Ventures to keep up shipstation
is the tool that gives smaller
businesses and independent sellers the
ability to keep up and keep customers
happy when you use shipstation your
shipping costs stay low executing orders
is simple and fast and returns are easy
as someone who sells physical copies of
all my books on my own website
pursuitofwonder.com I know how much of a
challenge and hassle it can be to deal
with the whole shipping process ship
station however has made it simple and
efficient effortlessly integrating
basically everywhere you sell online
like Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify and more it's
incredibly easy to incorporate into any
pre-existing process if you ever have or
do order one of my books on
pursuitawwonder.com your shipment will
have been processed through ship station
which by the way if you enjoyed this
video I think you'll really enjoy my
newest book millions of little threads
from a simple dashboard you can easily
track and manage every order automate
routine shipping tasks print shipping
labels and compare rates and times to
optimize every Shipment shipstation has
been a huge help in making sure the
prices and weights on shipments are
right and it automatically updates the
pricing when needed and with up to 84
off USPS and UPS rates shipstation
always ensures that you're getting great
deals with all the time and money saved
you can focus on other essential parts
of your business needed to keep it going
and growing all year long go to
shipstation.com Pursuit and sign up for
a free 60-day trial at shipstation.com
Pursuit
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]